human society is extremely complex and
fragile built upon various pillars one
of them is the honeybee one out of three
meals eaten by humans is made possible
by honeybees they are so important that
if all the honeybees were to die out
thousands of plants would follow which
could lead to millions of people
starving in the following years on top
of that honeybees have a huge economic
impact the dollar value of plants
pollinated by them each year is around
265 billion food we take for granted
would just stop existing without them or
there would be a massive decrease in
productivity food including apples
onions pumpkins and also plants used for
feeding livestock and thus extremely
important for our milk and meat einstein
is often quoted as having said if
honeybees die out humans will follow a
few years later actually he probably
didn't say that but there might be some
truth in the statement it's unsettling
but honeybees have started to disappear
millions of hives have died in the last
few years beekeepers all over the world
have seen an annual loss of 30 to 90
percent of their colonies in the us
alone bees are steadily declining from 5
million hives in 1988 to 2.5 million
today since 2006 a phenomenon called
colony collapse disorder has affected
honeybees in many countries and we're
not entirely sure what's causing it all
we know is that it's pretty serious
[Music]
over the last few decades bees have seen
an invasion of very dangerous foes
parasites straight out of a horror movie
like a carapace woody microscopic mites
that infect the trachea that's the
breathing tubes of bees here they lay
their eggs and feed from the fluids of
their victims weakening them
considerably and spending their whole
life inside the bees or varroa
destructor a fitting name because they
can only reproduce in honeybee hives and
are one of the bees greatest enemies the
female mite enters a honey bee brood
cell and lays eggs on the bee lava
before it's about to pupate and before
the hive bees cover the cell with a wax
capping the eggs hatch and the young
mites and their mother feed on the
developing bee in the safety of the
capped cell the bee is not normally
killed at this stage just weakened so it
still has enough strength to chew its
way through the wax capping and release
itself from the cell as it does it
releases the mother mite and her new
offspring from the cell and these are
free to spread across the hive starting
the process over again in a cycle of
about 10 days their numbers grow
exponentially and after a few months
this can lead to the collapse of the
entire beehive once outside of the cell
adult mites also suck the bodily fluids
of bees and weaken them considerably to
make things worse they also transmit
viruses that harm the bees even more and
can lead to birth defects like useless
wings but there are other threats too
such as viruses and fungi
under normal circumstances
these phenomena should be manageable and
are not enough to explain the horrendous
amount of dying going on in bees over
recent years new insecticides have been
introduced that are deadly to bees
neonicotinoids a chemical family similar
to nicotine was approved in the early
1990s as an alternative to chemicals
like ddt they attack insects by harming
their nervous systems today they are the
most widely used insecticides in the
world globally they saw sales of 1.5
billion euros in 2008 representing 24
percent of the global market for
insecticides in 2013 neonicotinoids were
used in the us on about 95 percent of
corn and canola crops and also on the
vast majority of fruit and vegetables
like apples cherries peaches oranges
berries leafy greens tomatoes potatoes
cereal grains rice nuts grapes and many
more
bees come into contact with the toxin
while collecting pollen or via
contaminated water often bringing
material into the hive where it can
accumulate and slowly kill the whole
colony the toxins harm bees in a variety
of horrible ways in high enough doses it
quickly leads to convulsions paralysis
and death but even in small doses it can
be fatal it may lead to bees forgetting
how to navigate the world so bees fly
into the wild get lost and die alone
separated from their hives if this
happens often enough a hive can lose its
ability to sustain itself we know that
neonicotinoids are harmful to bees and
that we urgently need an alternative to
it but there are billions of dollars to
be made in delaying this studies
sponsored by the chemical industry
magically appear to prove a much lower
toxicity to bees compared to those
produced by independent scientists there
are even more factors contributing to
the demise of bees like too much genetic
uniformity crop monocultures poor
nutrition due to overcrowding stress
because of human activities and other
pesticides each of those factors on its
own is a major problem for bees but
together they probably account for
colony collapse disorder with parasites
upping their game in recent decades the
honeybees are now fighting for survival
it would be a catastrophe if they lost
this fight this is a conundrum we have
to solve if we want to continue living
with a relative abundance and diversity
of food humanity is deeply
interconnected with earth and the other
life forms on it even if we pretend that
we're not we have to take better care of
our surroundings if not to preserve the
beauty of nature than at least to ensure
our own survival
this video is supported by the
australian academy of science which
promotes and supports excellence in
science see more at nova.org.eu
it was a blast to work with them so go
check out their site our videos are also
made possible by your support on
patreon.com recently we passed an
important milestone which is why there
will be an additional video in july if
you want to support us and become part
of the kotskazak bird army check out our
patreon page